so without pointers we'd find it really
difficult to build a general purpose CPU
that can do anything rather me drawing
it let me get out my back from thing of
the original IBM pcs 8088
and effectively when the Mac boots up
when the PC boots up they boot up like
this now what do we have inside a CPU
well is there's a bit of it which will
do all the arithmetic and do all the
logic so add numbers together it all do
various boolean algebra things we'll
forget about them for now we'll talk
about them some other time probability
talked about them the other thing you've
got are registers so a register is just
literally a small place where you can
store a bit of information well some of
them do store a bit but actually going
to store a few more bits and then you'll
get a byte or maybe 2 bytes worth so
let's go with what the 8088 had and it
can store generally the registers of
either a bite or two bytes we have a
look at this book on program it the 8088
project book it's got a list in here of
the various bits inside it so we've got
we are the automatic logic unit some
registers here some more temporary
registers and then these general ones
here and a few more that we've got
around so we've got some 8-bit and
16-bit we can combine to use it either
way and then we've got these 16-bit oh
look
pointers we'll come back to that so all
these registers do is allow you to store
a 16-bit value or an 8-bit value so
they're built into the CPU and the
instructions in the CPU will let you set
a value in them add a value to what's in
something in there or read a value from
one then that's fine you've got what one
two three four a 16-bit or eight 8-bit
values that's not much data and you've
also got the problem is well where'd you
get the program from how do you get more
data out of your memory to exit well the
way you do that is if you look you have
other registers which are called pointer
and indexes and this is why you need
pointers or you can't build a computer
because what these are used for is that
these say well okay I don't have this
value here but I'm going to store here
where it is in memory so I'm going to
store in say for example the stack
pointer not the stack but I'm going to
store a value that points to where the
stack is in
memory now really easy way to understand
how pointers work think of it like the
index of the book so if I want to know
about the stack pointer I will go to the
index if I can find the index and
somewhere it says stack pointer here we
are stack pointer see pages 9 and 10 so
if I want to find out something I don't
go to page 9 of 10 where it is I go to
the index and it tells me where is a
link at page 9 and to pointers work
exactly like that they tell you where to
find the information just like an index
in a book simple right now why do we
need them to make the computer work
almost two reasons are any of them
firstly how do we execute code the code
the program the instruction that's going
to execute it's stored in memory and you
need to know where that is how does the
CPU do that go back to our thing and if
we look carefully we find among these
registers we talked about 16-bit pointer
registers oh look over here 16-bit
segment registers and the instruction
pointer another pointer again it's a
special register and all this is doing
is storing the value of where in memory
to find the instruction that you can X
cube so when the CPU wants to execute an
instruction which is what it does all
the time
it goes to the instruction pointer and
it's got the address of where that
instruction is so it'll look in the
instruction pointer it'll contain say F
F F F 0 in hex that's the initial point
where a PC will start executing code
when you switch it off so it goes to
that address looks at up in memory and
gets the value that's in memory and
reads it into the CPU where you can
start processing it and it'll get that
instruction execute it whatever it is
and then it'll increment the instruction
pointer by however big that instruction
was it 8088
instructions can vary in size if we want
byte to vise etcetera these days they
can get up to 16 bytes on an x86 chip
but it'll increase the instruction
pointer to point to the next instruction
and then it does the same thing so it
looks up where the instruction is in
memory fetches it and so on so if we
don't have pointers we can't actually
even execute code we need that
instruction pointer as it's called on
the other CPUs the program counter same
thing it's just clearer here on the x86
that this instruction point that we need
that to know where to go and get the
instructions so without pointers you
can't make a CPU work or get values from
memory at least that's fine for exiting
code but this needs to execute on data
how do we get the data in the same thing
we have pointers that contain the
address or registers that contain the
address of where data is in memory so
every time you access a variable in C
the assembly that's generated is almost
certainly going to be getting that out
at some point from memory and putting it
into a register in the CPU and that will
be done by having a pointer a value of
where this is in memory going and
fetching it and then using that in the
instruction that's being executed
whatever that might be to add saved on
to another register or whatever the CPU
needs doing so again without pointers
you can't get data from memory you can't
store data back into memory so you can't
build a computer without computers you
can forget your functional program you
can forget your Y Combinator you can
forget your actual a was your linked
list anything you cannot build a
computer without pointers these leads
happen all the time and so passwords are
being just dumped talent internet all
the time so there's this password list
called RockYou which is a bit of a game
changer in password cracking if that's a
thing and I and and basically it's 14
million or so passwords I think